ready yes
it will bend
the ultimate forged in fire match-up you
are the forest and fire Champion two
Champion planes in a deadly weapon
Showdown it will kill 20 blades 20
Champions you decide the winner forged
in fire Madness
the Japanese oh no my name is Keaton
Goddard I've always enjoyed working with
my hands and I just came across the
video one day of a guy making a knife
out of a file I was like that's kind of
cool so I tried it and just kind of grew
from there
the Japanese Ono was a long battle ax
used by the Samurai Warriors during the
17th century measuring nearly six feet
long these intimidating pole axes were
used to destroy barricades and smash
opponent's Armor after becoming feudal
Japan's official police force during the
Edo period the samurai used their Ono to
keep the peace which they accomplished
for over 250 years
never heard of it never seen it a little
bit worried about figuring out how to
make the whole thing out of one piece
because it's pretty big and it's kind of
an awkward shape so it's gonna be a
tough challenge
the Horsemen's ex my name is Alex Ruiz
and I forged blades on nights and
weekends I used to make Hammers and
tongs for blazemists and I got bit by
the bug describe myself in three words
loves to Forge used by mounted Knights
and armies the Horseman's ax became the
weapon of choice after body armor made
swords less effective
the heavier ax with its concave blade
allowed Horsemen to strike more
effective blows using a sweeping
overhead stroke that penetrated armor
early depictions of medieval warfare
shows the X cleaving an opponent's
helmet delivering a fatal strike
in the film Sleepy Hollow the Headless
Horseman wields a Horseman's ax
[Music]
because the final round I'm back here on
Nantucket I'm gonna make a Japanese Ono
so I start by trying to widen the steel
with the drawing hammer and I realize
it's going to make my ax Way Too Thin so
I take the bra steel and I'm just
hitting it into the Anvil
so if I upset it it'll get fatter and I
can draw it wider from that thickness
not only is it getting thicker but I'm
also starting to get that Crescent shape
that I'm looking for I need to quench
this thing as soon as possible
[Music]
foreign
I did it
nice and straight
oh this is great dude I'm so happy it's
time to do some casting I'm casting the
heart ornaments that are going to go
around the holes in the ax Artistry and
craftsmanship are very important to me
so I want to incorporate that
I put some bronze Into The Crucible get
the bronze melting
I pull them out cool them off in some
water it's just looking really good
perfect the accent is pretty much done
shiny next is figure out this handle
just gonna use this piece of Hickory
got a nice straight grain to it I head
over to the Bell grinder I just start
hogging off material I'm just trying to
get it down to a manageable size because
I don't really have a lot of time
I'm also shipping the end of the Hickory
so that it'll slide into the socket of
the ax head
and I got to do one more thing drill the
hole and then put that pan in and peen
it over
and we're done
am I going to be making another one of
these anytime soon oh no
[Music]
got this big block of 4140 it's a really
good impact Steel
if anything's gonna hold up to hitting
something it's going to be that 4140
head 4140 body I may have five days but
if the competition taught me anything
work fast work diligently in case I run
into a last minute issue
getting that spread out another inch and
a half to be past minimum is my biggest
challenge
cutting these little Nubs in hoping that
I can open them up this way okay I gotta
add some width
this is not going to become five and a
half or six inches I'm gonna have to
start over but I'm keeping the spike my
plan now is to cut it right here and I'm
gonna Forge weld this to this I'm happy
I've got something that's solid and it
looks like an ax I got the Bell hook
teamed over now need a heat treat it's a
tense moment I'm gonna heat treat one
section and the other heat treat will
make or break my Edge literally and
figuratively
hahaha
oh now that the heat treat's done I'm
testing my weapon on a piece of sheet
metal I want to see what kind of damage
it'll do
nothing loose
it will bend
welcome to the Keel test it's time to
find out what kind of lethal damage your
owners will do find it out it will take
your weapon and deliver some lethal
blows on this ballistics dummy let's see
if your onos can be in oh yes oh yeah
let's do this
all right teams let's talk about your
Ono here
at first when I picked it up I was like
oh wow that's light
but then when I wielded it I was like oh
yes this thing stayed on it's solid your
edges they're sharp and that's why it
dug in very deep the overall sir your
owner was on oh yes
and it will kill thank you the
Horseman's ax it's actually two weapons
in one it's got an edge that can
lacerate and chop and a spike that can
penetrate and Crush bones to see what
kind of lethal damage your ax will do I
will take your Horseman's ax and deliver
lethal blows on this ballistics dummy
Alex you're up next you ready yes
this way
Alex your weapon here is a little bit on
the heavy side
but you know what it is well balanced
the edge of your blade here cut deep
into chest cavity and it broke the bones
your Spike here right into the heart and
of course on the swing it pretty much
just disemboweled the dummy right there
your weapon
will kill yes thank you
welcome to our strength test bamboo wall
chops now to push your owners to the
Limit I'm going to beat them repeatedly
against a strong thick springy bamboo
see how you feeling let's do it
looks like we get hung up
all right Kevin good job it's a nice
light fast easy to swing my favorite
aspect is how you have the wood going
all the way through and split up top
here your edges are still good good job
thank you ice can be very brutal on an
edge so I'm going to take your
Horsemen's ax and repeatedly strike into
these large blocks of ice to see how
well they hold up Alex you ready yes I'm
ready
[Music]
all right
now Alex your Horseman's ex did quite a
job on that ice
everything's still tight your edges
still razor sharp thank you
so all in all very nicely done
now it's your turn which weapon will you
choose forged in fire Madness